afternoon everybody thank you very much
for coming to join us this afternoon
today we're having our panel discussion
on the future of dot Knights I'm going
to introduce our speakers and then tell
you a little bit about the format for
today so first of all is Damien Edwards
he leads the program management team for
dotnet application frameworks at
Microsoft covering asp.net and he has
been on that core entity framework and
entity framework or WinForms and the.net
base class library it's a lot David
Fowler is a partner software architect
at Microsoft on the ASP med team and as
a creator of signal or he has also been
a major voice in the development the
dotnet core and asp net course since
their inception julie Lerman is a
leading authority on entity framework
about which he has written books and
altered multiple Pluralsight courses
she is a Microsoft regional director
domain driven design advocate and docker
captain scott allen is also an author
floral site author and Microsoft
Regional Director on the side he blogs
hosts a podcast and presents at
conferences around the world and I'm
Brian Hogan I have a podcast blog and I
have a few more presentations this week
the format for the discussion today is
the following I've prepared some
questions to for each of the panelists
I'm going to give him a few minutes to
answer the question directly and then
open it up to the rest of the panel for
a couple more minutes before moving on I
aim to leave 15 to 20 minutes for
audience questions and we have some
volunteers to move around with
microphones I will ask you the audience
to keep your questions brief and clear
when that time comes so my first
question goes to Damien what are you
most happy with are excited about in.net
core 3 Wow um as folks probably know I
hope they know there's a lot of stuff in
dotnet core 3 we did a thing this
morning about stuff that people may not
know much about and then we fill in our
rapid-fire stuff I could say you know
the desktop stuff is super exciting
because we're enabling existing app
types and new workloads and dotnet core
on windows obviously blazer but
everyone's heard that yes if blazer
exists hiding it's gonna be great but
I'm not gonna give that
my answer there's a whole bunch of
wonderful stuff but I think I'm actually
most excited about it says happy you're
excited I'm gonna pick excited because
excitement doesn't necessarily mean that
it's all going to be great it's actually
gonna be a little bit scary but I am
most excited about is what we're doing
with regards to thinking more about how
we integrate and leverage open source
now obviously dotnet core has been open
source since almost the beginning but
over time we've been looking at
different ways and thinking about we've
had a couple of failed experiments with
how we integrate with open source so a
template is a good example we have we've
well up until now we've shipped Newton
soft Jason in our template so we've
actually shipped it as part of the
framework which is not the case now in
three oh and so we're making some
changes with regards to how we think
about what is the core platform of net
core and asp.net core and then how we
layer on dependencies and extra
functionality on top of that there's
been a realization as certainly in the
app frameworks team and my team that we
can't do it all by ourselves we want net
to be a platform for any developer to
build anything they want and we can't do
that with the team size that we have at
Microsoft like we have a certain type of
thing that we need to be able to deliver
and focus on and then we really need the
wider dotnet ecosystem to make dotnet as
great as it can be but we also want to
deliver n2n solutions to customers for
the most important challenges that they
have and that means sometimes really
embracing and even recommending
particular net open source libraries and
so we're going through a process of
right now figuring out a good framework
for doing that so you'll see some new
things that might ship in some of our
templates and net core three we've done
a great effort with G RPC where we
actually partnered with the cloud native
Foundation and Google to build an
alternate implementation G RPC for
dotnet core built on top of a spinet
core and we're shipping that in the Box
in dotnet core 3 even though it's not
technically owned by Microsoft even
though we wrote most of the code so
that's a new area for us we haven't done
that before and for me this is just the
beginning of the next phase of dotnet
open source so I'm super excited about
that what are other people excited about
blazer
like the easy way your ads it okay
can you expand on why oh no I was
kidding but honestly is looking like a
very promising model for developing
client client base applications the
assignment is kind of insane when I
first saw it I was blown away I saw it
here last year I was here last year no
no no sorry two years music two years
ago years ago for me Steve and Damien
sat down for like lunch and Steve was
like how could a thing yeah and I show
you already huh and then if you show it
and we really you did this like
overnight no it wasn't like three months
but whatever is amazing and the
reception has been kind of crazy I think
like I never fitted it to be that that
well like I said in the community so I
think it is very promising going forward
and then looking towards things like
native development did I see a thing
called is it kind of public it blooder
that's okay there's a thing that I got
hot the future sounds goofy but I
there's applications out there that I
add that are still wind forms that have
never been ported because what would you
port them to and it's just in a way it's
kind of exciting the Microsoft is
looking at these older technologies and
moving them forward I think it's awesome
Julie do you have something in
particular well one of the connected to
these things sorry connected to this is
the fact that entity framework not EF
Corbett entity framework is being fixed
up to work on dotnet core three I
actually you know I had to see I haven't
used es6 in so long I I was like hitting
my head on my desk so much going how do
those initializations work again I
forgot everything I'll go watch my
course or something but I was like ah
you know I gotta see this so I actually
did I you know created a little is
peanut core 3 I do the whole thing on my
Mac right that's cool
with on my Mac in Mac OS not parallels
whole thing on my Mac with with ef6 3
in asp net core 3 using dependency
injection and then of course I had to
add in sequel server for Linux moniker
like the hole it was it was amazing that
I could do all of that on a Mac move on
to the next one for David can you talk
about some of the major performance
improvements in my core three things
like HTTP two-tiered compilation fast
Jason and like sure I think it's more
fun that's what so whatever using the
distance to realize are actually a big
one for me it's the first time I've seen
an asynchronous Jason person at this
allocate at all it literally only
allocates the obvious that you are being
that are being produced and I it was a
kind of a big effort on our team to make
that work end-to-end and it and the
benefits are showing up knowing our
benchmarks so our just image marketing
is like 2x faster because it's new async
parsing and there's no blocking in the
entire pipeline I think that's super
impressive the thread pool actually got
some pretty good information as well so
if you're in an async state machine and
you await over and over and over in the
same async method it will never allocate
it ok once and then never again and
that's due to having this new interface
called iff work item that we showed this
morning in our talk and we now implement
that interface on this day machine
itself so you can kind of cue the
continuation over and over to the same
object over and over some more
improvements in asp net core we made the
plain text benchmark for middleware and
routing allocation free if you don't
have any real parameters if you don't
have any a Massena pipeline we literally
allocate nothing once you have a
connection running that that was a big
effort with me and Ben and the BCL team
to add a bunch of primitives all came to
get to the tomb two minutes dispute
Alliance and reto allocate anymore
beyond that I'm thinking of what else
did we do that was kind of big in 300 I
was reading about there's some
improvement in garbage collection the
memory the false yet the memory default
so the GC in in sense dotnet I guess 2
or whatever was kind of greedy about
about memory so server GC really means I
am the process on the machine that's
gonna eat all the memory so if you have
more than one
well guess what to use are five memories
so in the new world of containers people
are seeing issues where you set up a
container limit to a very small value
and it wouldn't work super well so in
three oh we could we spent a bunch of
time trying to figure out what are
better smart defaults for container
based environments and now you can say
GC I want you to use this memory as a
Mac so if I find her Maxim memory for
example and they will respect that limit
and kind of accordingly so GC limits was
a big one I'm tiered compilation it's
funny it we spoke about this theoretical
thing the JIT was always a trade-off
between a slow startup or a fast
throughput and over the course of dotnet
there were kind of different trails that
were being missed with engine this is a
super common thing that happens on that
where you preach it the assembly before
it runs so you don't pay for JIT time
there were issues where and Jen would
would generate code to hard so you see
you couldn't it was version brittle was
what it was called I'm brittle engine so
the code must be so we made a new tech
called ready to run and the issue with
that was since you couldn't a super
engine anymore it was slower so we had
to invent a third thing tear compilation
that makes with makes with that this
this less brittle engine to JIT more
after the fact right but the whole the
whole theory was if you can giant ears
so you start you start off with really
slow code on you get very fast so you
get faster it up very slow and then as
you get further along you you the
tearing from tier 1 tier 2 you generate
better code right
so tear composition came and on that
core 2.2 million make some things lower
so it was off by default and through
there's no AMA by default because we
figured a good place to put it
what default I saw that system that
console has received improvements as
well strangely got faster so we had like
pilot the cross flights tough weave
winner is no secret like.net stole a bit
faster on Windows for a lot of scenarios
it has a 20-year pedigree
and so a lot of links implementation
newer so we've been learning as we go
and in three oh there's even
yeah and now I'm working there was a
there was a change made like last week
where I wasn't even think of that news
that string comparisons there were a
kiss insensitive on the next were 20%
slower and it was this super obscure
issue with the evoking on the next run
it's fixed now
so we're trying to go through and figure
out how to close the gap between the two
OSS because people still see us as being
windows first and we we kind of still
are for the most part this morning you
had the business I was win windows x86
mm-hmm that's just your your default oh
it's a Windows machine I didn't want to
put the demo so make a point that's a
fair point yeah Oh Junior Scott do you
have any anything about performance
coming in not treated interesting I
think they covered everything I was
interested in faster is always better
yes Julie what change is an entity
framework or three are you most happy
with and where do you see entity
framework going over the next few years
well my my ideas of the what's new and
great what's great about changes in the
F core 3 might be different than other
people's there's there's this one little
change I've been waiting for him so
happy about which is for the complex
types so anybody here who uses DDD and
loves value objects there was there was
something that just did not work even
though we could use we could use the new
oh my gosh I called him complex types
owned entities the new owned entities
feature so I use that to write and
support entity framework to be able to
map value objects but there was some
really important facets of how value
objects work and use that it didn't
support so I you know we came up with a
little workaround hack for it so that
was that was fixed I don't think I need
to go into the details about that so I'm
just really happy because as EF core
hasn't evolved its ability to support
the way I want to write my domain models
entity framework or has just gotten
better and better so that an
framework can actually create the right
data model and map directly into the
database where I don't have to say it's
there's too much conflict here I'm gonna
have to make a separate data model and
map it so it just keeps getting better
and better one thing that's really
important that's going on with EF core 3
is that they're rewriting the query
engine how the how the query compilation
happens and they're doing that because
there's a lot of conflicts with what
methods get come get compiled for
client-side evaluation and what methods
get compiled for server-side evaluation
and how a lot of those defaults were
working and a lot of that how that
worked was carried forward carried for
it from entity framework and they hadn't
really paid a lot of attention to it
before so since the F core has just
gotten so much stronger I mean as of EF
core 2.2 I thought it was like really
super duper production-ready
like no question it was really really
strong and so now they're able to really
go back and start focusing on some of
these other things so they're rewriting
how the query compilation works
unfortunately it's like you know when
your kid breaks their arm you take your
kid to the doctor and the first thing
the doctor has to do is break it again
so that it sets properly so like right
now they're actually recommending be
really careful with preview 6 because
there's a lot of things that aren't
working because they're so busy revising
that query that query pipeline but it's
really really important it's amazing
that they're able to take the time to do
that right now will it feel very
familiar to dotnet sorry to enter
grammar core 2 within the framework feel
free feel very similar will it be the
same syntax what do you have to change
those there is actually a big list of
breaking changes right now but the team
has been really fantastic about listing
them very carefully explaining why the
breaking change is happening
explaining what is you can do to go
around it I don't know how that's going
to work out when you
core 3 actually comes out so like big
new features like from from my
perspective I mean there's not a lot of
new like important features it's more of
this stuff they're finally getting to go
back and dig in and make what they have
even better Damien do you've anything to
add yeah I'm actually everything Julie
said there is actually the vast majority
of the focus of the team at the moment
and they're doing a lot of hard work on
that I'm again kind of excited about the
provider landscape and so we've we had
we were lucky enough to hire engineer
who wrote the Postgres provider so now
he works on the EF course team which is
fantastic and he's bringing a lot of
that which has been wonderful for us
because with one of the reasons we've
done so well and the tech empower
benchmarks is that the pedometer
database there is Postgres on Linux and
his provider was really good and when we
did a big performance push for the last
round of tech empower he really pushed
hard to improve the Postgres driver you
know in coupling with the EF team at the
time and now we're bringing a lot of
that learning and we're pushing some of
those things down into a deonette itself
and we're adding new capabilities to a
do net based on what we've seen the
other frameworks do in those benchmarks
as well and so it things like batches
batching query batching and query
pipelining so that you can optimize the
connection between your app server and
the database at the database driver
level for dotnet this is that related to
why
the data client
sequel client why sequel client was kind
of pulled out so that's a different
story do you want to hear that start you
and I you can tell me another day very
shortly a space so yeah so they be the
Microsoft sequel client was a recently
announced last month we announced that
the Microsoft sequel client will be the
one that's in dotnet framework and the
one that currently ships in dotnet core
and as a package will basically be
frozen that one will be there forever
so if you've got an app that's using
that it's fine and then they have pulled
an EF like EF did you know we're however
many years ago and they're building an
out-of-band version which is the same
API to start with but they've changed
the name space it'll be Microsoft dot
whatever it is
that's equal client and that'll be in
packages and they're doing that so that
they can create agility the problem
today is that it's the same codebase in
the same client in dotnet framework as
it is in net core and that makes it very
difficult to make changes because if you
make a change you get it wrong you break
one and a half billion machines
wonderful framework on full framework
because it's a part of Windows and it
turns out that in dotnet framework
update four point seven point three or
whatever it was sequel client made a
change and unfortunately broke EF and
broke a bunch of things and so there was
a huge fire drill and this kind of set
the thing in my plus there was features
that we didn't have in the super client
in.net core and that was again due to
these harvest complexities so decoupling
it's going to enable them to do much
you know better work much quicker
without that risk so I'm super excited
about that as well I think it'll be a
benefit to third party yeah and another
way the other thing is that it kind of
puts it on equal footing so like the
sequel client isn't in the Box anymore
EF isn't in the Box anymore in dotnet
core 3 you know obviously the tooling
suggests EF the templates will have EF
but it's not part of the framework so if
you don't use EF and used a pro or
something else which is great you won't
pay the cost of it have being in the
framework and if you don't use sequel
use Postgres or or my sequel some cosmos
DP Cosmos TB whatever it might be that
client is not there because you didn't
reference it so yeah it's pretty cool I
think that's important for EF to go
beyond relational databases I mean 10
years ago if you asked me to store data
I would say relational database that's
the only way to go and five years ago I
started using on a regular basis
and these days when I look at solutions
that I have and working on their sequel
server plays a part but then there's a
lot of stuff and oh no sequel database
and there's stuff and a redis cash and
there's a lot of stuff honestly actually
it's sitting in CSV files and blob
storage because all it's going to do is
get crushed and slam together in an
apache spark cluster so why pay for a
sequel server when it can just sit and
blob storage for cheap but at the same
time sometimes it would be nice to
interact with that data using code and I
keep thinking if the entity framework
could provide something like the f-sharp
type providers where I can get to that
stuff in a strongly typed manner and
yeah maybe there's some query
translation to makes things more
efficient that would be awesome I'll
move us on discuss a lot of people want
to see C sharp and dotnet evolve even
more quickly but do you worry that
leaves a lot of people behind I don't
think people getting left behind is as
much of a concern as it was let's say
during the dotnet framework days just I
do see a lot of even the bigger
companies now understanding the fact
that this new world this new industry is
gonna be fast they have to embrace open
source projects that are getting updated
and deprecated on a regular basis they
have to work with if they want to work
with the latest technologies like C
sharp and dotnet core there's gonna be
frequent updates and if they don't stay
up-to-date then there's ramifications
for that I do worry sometimes that
people get confused I mean if you walk
into a shop that hasn't been closely
paying attention to Microsoft they're
still thinking about dotnet framework
and they're thinking that's the future
of the dotnet framework and they're not
they don't understand the relationship
between dotnet framework and dotnet
cores yet it just takes a little bit of
explaining to get them over the hurdle
and then they're fine but I think I
think we have had some confusion in the
industry just what the different
directions we're going Judy do you see
that what entity framework like we're
talking about breaking changes again is
that a concern for you it's it's not for
me personally because I also know this
is I mean right now the breaking changes
are there because they're in the middle
of working on it right in in the
previews and you know that explanation
that I have about that the broken arm I
use that with a lot of things but I
think it's really important to just you
know be patient and and let them get
there but get there with you know what
they're doing so I yeah I don't think
that anything is for production you know
by the time its release I mean just
don't use previews in production and and
Kenny
is it okay if I just say duh it's not
offensive to anybody like don't ya don't
use previews in production I mean it's
hard because people want to get ready
for a new release so they're there at
least the team is set you know here's
what's going on with preview six you
know if you really really need to see
these other features and you want to
test it that's fine but just be really
really aware of it David and Damian do
use preview them produce previews as
much as you Father akhi f6 right now I
mean the preview thing is super
interesting like we you know we've done
a lot of frequent previews for three
over at the point we're doing monthly
previews and we're ramping down to
release in September right now but using
previews is actually super critical
using the production is a whole
different thing all right testing and
testing and feedback is super super
important for us because the reality is
given the way dotnet works
it's creeping out breaking changes if we
don't get the feedback before we mark it
as non preview it's done like the only
way to apply your feedback for a lot of
cases is to make a break and that
usually makes a lot of people upset if
it's in quite a mainline scenario so we
really appreciate folks using the
previews and being very vocal with their
feedback even if it's great stuff I love
what you're doing here I don't have any
other feedback except this works really
well that's actually really important
for us because being blind to it is
actually one of the biggest problems
that we have as a team I'm happy to say
that 3oh is one of the highest used
previews we have ever had in the.net
core era so we've been super happy with
that like genuinely really really happy
to see those numbers I'm worried I so
and from a snack or 102 to only made a
huge breaking change to the off stack
and it was painful it was yeah pretty
terrible so we've been very very wary of
doing that from 2:00 to 3:00 but we have
made a series of spamming of bread
containers across the board some small
some big and we think they're not a huge
deal but I feel like we're still trying
to figure out if it's okay to do it like
we keep saying yeah major versions
breaking changes it'll be fine gonna say
like that is nice and Amy's not there
it's not bricks today guys
but we are we are trying to see if it's
okay to break things that we think
aren't used very heavily in the past
people assume that you know everything
is heavily used so you couldn't do
anything so that things just got blurred
by by nature of that but now we're
trying to dip our toe into seal okay
wanted to you can't bring an entire
public API that is like the main main
use case but what if we can break this
nexus over here or that one over there
or this thing over here that isn't so
popular to see if we can see evolve
things without having to like be carried
the cross forever right
and that's one of the big differences
Bend on a framework and on a car is it
doesn't framework you just can't break
anything because it's in place it's on
Windows you break it you make it one and
a half billion people sad donate car you
get to choose when you take the change
you know modular support which is I'm
I'm sure we'll end up talking about but
we can do side by side releases you can
take a major release when you want to
take the major release but to Julie's
point before or and Scott's point you
have to adapt to how the industry is
moving right now things are moving
quicker but there are lead times like
it's not that we tell you one week oh if
just drop support for this and you have
to lock the next thing next week if you
keep in tune and at least your finger on
the pulse such that you're not
forgetting about you know keeping up to
date years at a time you do have quite a
lot of runway right and so with the LTS
supports for dotnet core you get three
years and there's two years in between
each release like that's a fair amount
of time and then brakes aren't it's not
reap lat it's like you know there's a
list of ranking changes and you go
through and you make those changes and
then you you're on the new version the
thing is our tools don't help you know
if you read our blogs are on Twitter or
if you weren't leading social media how
did you know that
LTS is gonna expire next next week
that's right and we're talking about
though I'm not gonna move us on yeah
back to entity framework and Julie do
you find companies are still reluctant
to adopt entity framework and what can
be done about that I could just say no
and then we can move on on the sky I
let's see can I talk about EF core like
people who were on EF six and moving to
EF core there was definitely a lot of
reluctance there and people needed to
see
out in the wild not just you know blog
posts and stuff that that was really
important for people to see that other
people were using it and then again that
you know that difference between
with.net core to from 1.0 to 2.0 and
then with EF core it really was well if
core 2.2 for me like there was just a
couple extra things that really was like
yes now it has the things that I want in
it and I think so companies watch that
and pay attention to that and then you
know reluctance to move to EF core
there's I mean any ORM there's always
going to be the people who just want to
you know write their own sequel and have
that comfort level you know they want to
just have their own stuff and you know I
just I am NOT like ever there to like
proselytize like oh you have to use
entity framework I mean I one thing I
always talk about with people is you
know kind of the 80/20 rule I think you
know something like an entity framework
or an ORM there your it's going to take
care of probably 80% of just that you
know basic stuff that you're doing and
then 20% go and you know write write
your own store procedures and views and
use your own logic you know then then
you've got a huge benefit from from
using it but yeah I don't see that kind
of pushback that we saw with an entity
framework at the beginning I think you
know people yeah it's been around for a
really long time people kind of gotten
used to it now it's got a you're nodding
alone well I I just had an experience
about two months ago sitting with a team
that their their argument basically came
down to two reasons one reason was that
they were afraid a user would be able to
do something in the database that the
user wasn't supposed to be able to do
and I so and for that reason they want
to do everything to go through store
procedures but when I sat down and
dug into that I said do you do you
actually flow the user identity through
to the database call well no we have a
connection string I'm like well then
even if you had a stored procedure you
wouldn't actually know who that user is
unless you somehow passed some pass
along some ID or some token so my point
of this is going to be that if you don't
use the entity framework that's fine
just make sure you do it for valid
reasons and their other argument was a
little bit harder to talk them out of
this one but they basically believe that
iqueryable is too powerful to put into
the hands of developers so that's right
and for that reason they want all their
sequel code to be lovingly handcrafted
our teaching style and that's a hard
argument a problem to when they don't
trust the developers right yeah a
software shop doesn't trust the
developers reluctances well that's it's
a base always take a big bag of M&Ms
when you go talk to the GPS data is
always bright like the the data access
area of any stock has always been fairly
vehemently protected right they say like
data is still king queen Emperor right
it is is really really important to a
company and like making a data access or
control decision that changes the status
quo in a company in my experience has
always been never taken lightly so I
totally understand a lot of the you know
the emotion around data access libraries
and data access techniques and all
around all the rest of it and I'll just
say they use what makes you happy
whatever works for you is fine but the
end of Scott's point do it for good
reasons and don't have a problem with
sitting down and talking about and
re-evaluating whereas you know new
technologies become available but if it
works for you
knock yourself out when I showed in a
client they they were the DBAs were
really fighting against it because there
was one one really dumb query that was
just taking a really long time and I
said go write the stored procedure and
bring it back to me right and we put the
stored procedure in there and said let
you know for this hard thing let's use
your you know your intelligence in New
York
to solve the problem and then you know
the DBA was like oh okay
right like I'll you know I'll be
responsible for the stuff you really
need me for and then let any framework
take care all the dumb stuff it's like a
I write a I take care of the easy stuff
and then the God let the human people do
the creative work David if you could
rewrite that's entirely without worrying
about changes what would you change
[Laughter]
project files I'm kidding
solution files probably yes would be a
big one solution files are just terrible
there was an effort about three years
ago to try and make a new fiction
followed they failed miserably
hoping it will come back again because I
really want to be a consistent format
for msbuild I wish I wish it wasn't XML
it's not Yama but not something else I
think one big thing I think C sharp is
too verbose I think it comes from its
roots of Java I can I wish it was more
turfs one thing I see is when I
interview students from college they
know Python and something that was is
Python and like JavaScript and that and
I think the bar to entry like to write a
c-sharp hello world you have to do
namespace class method I hear they're
using and you're this far in to the map
this table before doing like
console.writeline and python you just
print hello world right I think I think
thinking about making sure you start
more verbose for connector W a little
would be a would be a big thing also I
change the naming of some things the
beginning ASP net core we tried super
hard to change the name do you know
hearts is to search for asp net the asp
net that term active server pages is
just tainted it's at like five years to
get core to mean something good five
years just like bad search terms bad bad
things thought is a good is a strong
brand but it doesn't really appeal to
the
who knew it was before like 20 years ago
I think some some cool name like not
node no no no it's not net so the one
thing you could change is like some
marketing marketing or engineering thing
know some other things I think c-sharp
is to object-oriented so maybe some more
structural type matching duck typing in
the runtime I'd like that that's walking
I think go does really well and there
there there be CL every single method in
in library and c-sharp has like no
checking for everything are gyu meant so
you start method on it's like this long
if argument is not no threat exception
you have like just bunch of bloat I
really hate seeing every method and I
wish we could figure out has made things
more concise and just look like the code
you want to see as a language feature
yeah thing yeah it's really kind of
painful to read I think that's not much
we try to do they have the world one
would say no I'm a bit more tempered
know we tried packages that didn't work
at all no that didn't work at all I'm
the NPM thing like we tried making
member donik or one oh you guys all were
part of that right everything was a
package all packages that was amazing
you could change anything in system
runtime could be different from system 3
if you wanted collections you have to
ask for it
like that theme cool in theory we all
loved it but ever practiced people hated
it so now I'm a bit more I'm a bit more
dialed back into League maybe xml's ok
[Laughter]
yeah anyone else want to chime in
defense of code to me is a something
that gets under my skin too because it's
difficult to open up a c-sharp file and
look at a public method and it's almost
like seeing ads on the right side of the
browser your mind just skips over all
that validation code to try to get to
the heart of what's going on and most of
my career has been either C C++ C sharp
and a lot of JavaScript and all those
languages I've had to deal with that
I've always had to had a lot of
defensive coding to make sure that
someone didn't pass you a bad argument
or you know we could make an argument
that in JavaScript it was even worse
because he had to wrap things in these
weird syntax if he's just to make sure
you didn't have a global escape I'm so
over all of that and it's what appeals
it's what makes F sharp appeal to me as
a language like getting rid of some of
that noise and being more terse about
things um that being said I think the
null checks coming out and c-sharp I
think will be be good all right
Scott's when running software there are
many ways to do it well but far more
ways to do it badly that still work and
meet business needs do you think
languages like C sharp and frameworks
like that net and tools that are around
that should guide us in the right
direction I think to some extent yes I
think that it always worries me when you
talk about language changes because I
don't know what's gonna be different
five or ten years from now when it comes
to language changes and specifically if
I think about things like async and a
wait-and-see sharp yes it makes it easy
to do any sinc programming and it's very
easy in the easy case but then you have
you know david has to write entire
wiki's about how you can screw things up
with a sink in a way and and that
worries me that that feature in the
language is so hard to misuse and then
the framework to I think it's easier to
make framework changes that help people
so if I think about the struggles I used
to have with HTTP client anyone have
HTTP client headaches I mean you were
basically screwed with that class no
matter what you did if you disposed it
like you're supposed to then socket
starvation if you keep one around
forever then you're not going to do any
deployments you know I gotta have feel
over so you're screwed no matter what
you do and so those types of situations
are the situations I'd like to see the
framework address aggressively of course
some of them you don't find out about
until it's been out and you you've seen
it in use for a few years and that's why
using previews are so important as as
risky as it can be for a lot of us bug
but even things like using exceptions
for flow control I've seen people doing
that do you think a framework or a
library
warned you or the visual studio should
jump in and say absolutely idea
absolutely and I think warning should be
Aires default yeah anyone else Julie
David Damien
got any ideas on this yeah we spent we
spent a lot of a lot of time doing about
this we see a lot of code like our daily
job emails from people at Microsoft
outside of Microsoft and not that he
actually came from me reading people's
code I'm going ah we're never even get
this right there is a lot of fear in the
team themselves for if we want to add a
new paradigm so I think await like
copied in rust JavaScript Python like
works really well we think in general
but legacy code kind of comes in there
kindly well you have legacy code and new
code new clothes beautiful
they both interact and then things off
the rails right and we haven't found a
way to kind of bridge that gap yet so
people are fearsome up for adding new
models that can solve the problem and
then we have sync oh they think new
async and new new async for things what
do you do now all right it's like the
sequel client like yes yes that's I I
think that's a perfectly great way to
solve that problem
you just have another library right in
that particular one because that was a
big problem Damien what's gonna happen
with that in that quarry 3.when dotnet v
comes along
will there be rewrites for us well no
Microsoft the rest no I mean as the
platform yeah we talk about breaking
changes and we take that very seriously
now the the reality is that as the
platform gets more mature we are as it
is now dotnet cause coming out to its
third release we have a million active
monthly users who have been using dotnet
core this year which is fantastic was a
good milestone to get over we have to be
careful and we don't we need to be we
need to have to find that flexibility
between changing things that are
obviously broken and sometimes for the
reasons you've talked about
now like we don't want people to fall
into pits of failure that we talked
about we want people to be set up for
success and we want the tools to help
them do that we want the language that
help them do that we want the framework
to help them to do that there's lots of
layers here that have to work well
together in order you know to make you
successful to make the developer
successful but we have a little legacy
that we also have to interact with we
can't make a clean break every year
there every two years or even every five
years we've got one right we got one and
it was 16 years after we did the first
one we don't get another one this is our
shot and so we have to figure out how to
ensure that when we now we're on this
new release cadence which is every year
we now sir bill this year every year
there will be a new major version of.net
core and every alternate version will be
a long term support release
so don't f5 will not be long term
support don't f5 is next November 2020
and it will be the next major version
after dotnet 3 there will be a doctor 3
1 before the end of this year which will
be long-term support so moving from
dotnet 3 or 3 1 to 5 will be trivial it
shouldn't be a big change at all whether
you're using ASP net or windfarms yeah I
know I see the eyebrows thing right it
went for us WPF console apps whatever it
is you're doing I'm not saying you won't
there won't be any breaking changes of
course there will be there always are
but the reality is other than that off
breaking change we've made between one
and two a lot of the time in a spin at
least right now most of the breaking
changes we end up making things that
affect program main and the startup
class and pretty much nothing else in
your app there's two files in your whole
app right because we have two sometimes
we have to change platform level things
or composite like main point routing
it's a great example in three Oh
to get the benefit you have to move to
the new API so you can consider that a
break and you can't use some of the new
features until you've moved to the new
API so you have to go and think about
that rewrite a small portion of your
startup class and then you're off to the
races there are a smaller braking change
throughout trait changes throughout the
rest of it but they are really small
like I can't think of anything that you
would have to go and change your
multiple files like a fine replace or
anything like that and even the ones
that we did make it your most them are
really esoteric like we make some change
that was a type that was public as now
internal but it's a type no one ever a
constructor that was public is now gone
and was a constructor you would never
have called because you're all using di
to get it anyway
right so it would have been created for
you so those are the type of breaking
changes that we tend to be breaking
right now I can't think of one that we
would make in five
I mean Never Say Never we don't know
what's gonna happen in the next six to
eight months and you know we haven't
even started yet we've got change a
platform three times though we have but
I think the third one the new one is
gonna be the ones right now we went from
packages and we added the runtime store
then we went to shared framework and in
three oh we have composable shared
framework so we've kind of at the
pinnacle now you can use multiple shared
frameworks they can inherit from each
other and so far given the landscape of
what we can see in front of us
that's enough composition one more thing
coming for sure probably but whether it
will break anything I think the new
thing if we do it will compose on top of
what we have and so it won't break
anyone it'll just be a new tool that you
have available to you so yes no REO I
rewrite as a strong word yes you'll have
to make some changes you have to
retarget your app to five it is a major
version but yeah I think we'll be we'll
be okay that doesn't sound to me like
you use you use that in context of you
know it's small but it you know maybe
it's a break in change but rewriting
something in order to take advantage of
a new feature know that that doesn't
feel like something breaking to me that
feels like oh you know like I'm just
gonna implement this new thing right and
rewrite again is a strong term like
moving from a subpoena to a it's been a
core that's a rewrite it really is
moving from a spinet core one to two was
not a rewrite it was painful but it
wasn't a rewrite and two to 2.1 most
people do that under a day to one to two
to was usually instant you change your
TFM you update your packages you off to
the races
3:04 most people will be an hour's work
to move from 2x - 3 oh if you have a
slightly more complicated application it
might take you a day and then you don't
I mean to me that's pretty good
investment and you get advantage of all
the new features so yeah now where the
entity entity framework you know the
kinds of changes they're making the
query pipeline those could have like I
don't know if they're breaking changes
but behavioral changes so I think tests
are going to be really integration tests
are gonna be really really important
they're to make sure that stuff stays
consistent working the way you
anticipate
I'm worried about the meaning of the
meaning of major virgins if we do them
so often personally so shipping super
often is really great the rest feel like
major every year right what does that
mean does that mean you're you're not
fixing bugs every year is that mean
you're doing features over here so we
want it is but you know symptom Burmese
think so stem Burmese like minors early
fixes and patches and we patch every
we're still gonna patch but imagine
there's three oh then three one and five
yeah ah like whoa that seems like a day
it's just even though it is a number is
seeing them if feels big to me okay it
feels they oh okay well isn't that
something you usually make Kathleen
Dollard explain yeah lean out there like
let happily give this news and explain
to people because they're gonna trust
her if she says this is this is good
it's hard but it's good for everybody
I'd be like if Katherine said it's okay
I trust I trust her
Scott anything on this so I'm gonna open
it up to audience questions we have two
people with microphones and Niall at the
front already that's one place I'll
repeat it if you want to ask me the next
greatest security feature
okay so the question was what's the next
great of security
sorry if you want to ask a question
please let the two people I decided
microphones know so they can get to you
well this one's being answered but it
was a recent proposal put together on
how we would go about
deprecating api's moving forward
including in the BCL and that's
something that we've just never really
done in core FX layer we've done in a
snit core we've already started doing it
in the last couple of versions our
pattern now is we typically mark the API
obsolete in one major version like in
one of the miners within a major and
then we'll delete it in the next major
so there's a bunch of api's that were
marked obsolete and - - well - one
they're gone in three oh and a split
core
they'd never done that four core effects
before but now there's a proposal
together on how to potentially do that
and one of the big reasons is for
security so when things just become
unsafe we can actually have a path to
leave them what about their parties what
about their packages automatic what
about you need don't forget a
takács so that's another coming so right
now the only thing you can really do on
new guy's unlist a package which just
stops it showing up in search results
but they are working on the ability to
just a similar to I am p.m. is done to
be able to have a package declare that
it is deprecated and here's why and with
a recommendation of what you should do
instead I think all the way up to it
won't even let you use it anymore for
like the most critical critical critical
problems I mean I well it's it about
making it such about trust
sometimes you have to be mean to be all
the myriad mirror fees if that's
important to you I think we have another
question from removing a microphone
there and there's another person up here
that would like to ask question does it
work Oh oh my god again microphone okay
so what's your opinion for companies
where most services are still running
conduct and framework is the
strategically best time to migrate that
call right now or on to the two right or
wait for that five will the gap could
get smaller or not the gap won't get
smaller yeah so if you if you think
waiting for dotnet 5 will make it easier
to move from dotnet framework
it won't yeah Don deathcore 3 is the
tipping point in the sense of like API
surface area workloads that are
supported workloads meeting application
types win forms a spinnaker we've
already announced WCF will not be coming
to dotnet 5 web forms will not be coming
to dotnet 5 there are open source ports
of workflow and WCF that were sponsored
by Microsoft we're being kicked off and
now being maintained by the community
the wf1 is super early it's like three
weeks old so those might be options so
maybe if you really need that you would
wait for that or get involved with that
but in terms of dotnet itself I don't
see anything being added in 5 that will
make it easier three is getting C++ CLI
it's getting VB it's getting on Windows
it's getting wind forms a WPF like it's
getting all the things that would be
blockers for a lot of people so if you
need web forms stay on the framework
it'll be there forever any much a
rewrite yeah so you just don't unfair or
you can be ambitious and creative Rob
well you can come up with a migration
blend that we've worked with companies
who have migrated from web 4
just text on the backend code so it's
actually awesome to hear that because
that's just a message I want it to bring
home good report it right the thing that
the microphone is over here somewhere
hello um I was wondering how satisfied
or any unfulfilled visions you have for
tvp's in the sequel client er yeah that
whole experience for how we use tvp's I
don't know what that is
Kable value yeah table 90 parameter oh
okay I always yeah it mixed up between
the support for table values parameters
and table value functions aren't
parameters the parameters were subdued
eventually gets supported they they
definitely work I was just curious where
where I couldn't miss the question when
the glass whip Bert for sure so just and
to be fair I'm kind of being a bit
snarky about it no no no I I think
they're awesome to use but I feel like
the experience with how I have to use
them is not great but I'm curious if
it's on your mind at all over here hello
yeah there we go so how much further
along the explicitly managed memory path
do you expect c-sharp and on there to go
over time where do you think current
limitations are and how do you go about
finding solutions to those that may
involve changes to the language or the
runtime and that's a good speaking of
security there are there are this is the
tension this is one of the biggest
tensions I think in the evolution at the
platform moving forward whenever the
guys to language features and power is
how much power do we give developers
through the language and through the
type system and the runtime to do the
type of explicit memory management that
you're talking about while keeping
people like Niall and the rest of the
security community happy who have seen
all the problems that are caused by that
type of power and you know the folks on
the security folks in the dotnet team
publicly talked about this all the time
there was a thread on Twitter yesterday
with Levi and
because it was Kevin Jones made a
comment community member and Levi and
Barry kicked down I think I don't review
sorry no like yes please keep saying
things like this because the language
team was to go into all these crazy
things okay yeah I know balance so I
will say like the span for example which
was the last big one like this and refs
trucks doing those things is really hard
doing those things safely and you know
better than I do is like super difficult
and yeah there's obviously very smart
people who are working on this and they
they worried like they really stress
yeah I figure out how much to say so
there's been experiments where we tried
to look at no no unless they roughed
people on team love rust and they're
trying to see if we could bring the same
kind of thing to see sharp and it's
really ugly it gets ugly really fast for
us it's great language I'm recording
right it's a great language if you get
to compiles there there are people
looking at this stuff in both research
and the language team and there's
there's corruption between both teams
you're trying to figure out what it what
make sense to bring C sharp in real life
there's a ton of experiments in the wild
but I don't live blue see anything in
real life for a couple years everyone's
worried especially the security team
even adding span and buffer pulling to
the BCL like people lost their we're
still are still aren't very comfortable
doing it so I saw the microphone went to
the back hello
I didn't really hear the last question
so I'm sorry if this is the same one but
it was great while the GC handles memory
deallocation beautifully resource the
application is currently handled by the
what I think is a band-aid with I
disposable and the quite horrendous
disposable pattern that offers little in
terms of convenience over primitive
languages such as see what sorry it
makes you an ulcer is epic
sorry I'll go on it makes me as a
program a having to care about things
that are modern programming language
and/or runtime should handle for me
I think are there any plans for
something like per class opt in
automatic ref counting that guarantees
that the final area is run when my
object goes out of its last scope so I
don't have to care about using blocks
and chaining dispossess and implementing
verbose patterns all of which I can and
do get wrong there's new syntax in
c-sharp 8 where you can do using var so
it's not as noisy some of your sayings
and staff feel is bad but no there's no
class to ref coming to see well no to
c-sharp itself
there have been been efforts that have
been a part of to do in API is the
people like freak till again because
it's super scary but up calm memories
and everyone's kind of know we can't
want to calm c-sharp is GC is magical
I just possible is your probably your
best bet and if you want full control
just allocate memory yourself and just
don't worry about you can say anything
else but yeah there's no plans to to
have that kind of thing in arc
I guess sleep in c-sharp thank you after
I don't see the microphone go we have
hello question about C sharp features is
there any plan to support algebraic data
types like records or discriminated
unions is an f-sharp yes
how soon in the night agree to the next
version they're looking at those things
as at the top they were looking at some
of the variety I got punches I early on
they're looking at records records in
c-sharp 8 and then inheritance made it
super hard right and then they punted
the whole thing but at 9 - yeah and 9
who's gonna be around out of 5 I guess
maybe yeah yeah yes yeah there oh yeah
oh yeah those two things specifically
thank you anyone else if you don't I
have a few spoke gentleman over here
since we're on features for a long time
the way you developed was sort of a mix
of changing visual studio and the
language and libraries all together so
is this overall mix but now what core
Madonna core so much of the demos are in
Visual Studio code how does that change
how you feel about implementing features
if you're don't tie yourself so strongly
to Visual Studio um so let's yeah it's
an interesting question and there's been
folks internally who have wondered about
whether that is whether it was wise I
had to do so it is it is different you
don't to think about differently so with
when we started profit okay right which
turned into dotnet core it was we
started with the command line first
project file first mentality which is
where project Jason came from packages
first CLI from the beginning at cetera
center etc but we always always always
saw it as a base that had to be very
functional that you could then layer on
various different sort of developer
environments it was never intended that
we would abandon the idea of a
wonderfully integrated you know vertical
development environment with strong ties
to where you run in production I will
say it was much easier when we owned the
OS and the web server and the framework
and the runtime and the template the
height and the tool like it was all one
thing it was basically in one team
it was simpler but it was also quite
limiting right you know we going across
plat was never gonna happen
doing it that way and a lot of the other
innovations we've made we're really
never going to be possible doing that
but yeah it does change the way we think
about things and I will admit that it
does result in things not landing in the
same time sometimes like you don't land
a full experience end to end in one
release we often end up with well
there's a package available you can go
and try it and there's a bit of Docs
over here but there isn't any
intellisense in vs and there's no
template and there's no scaffolding and
right and so and then over time we look
at how many folks are using it and then
we decide what to prioritize in terms of
adding vs support
that type of thing so it has changed
those things but personally I love the
fact that people can feel productive in
vs code or in Rider or in vs or in a
web-based editor or just using the
command-line I want I love that and and
from what I've spoken to folks most
folks seem to like that too
the challenge is more on us to keep
delivering those nice end-to-end
solutions I have heard the complaint we
still hear it and where did the visual
and visual studio go I hate that I have
to read on my project file and I agree
like III like editing the project file
but I agree
you shouldn't have to they should be
easy gestures in vs for doing all the
main line things that you should be able
to do and we're lagging behind that on a
bunch of very important things right now
even some of the stuff we showed today
which are mainline things that we know
people want to do in 3 oh you probably
won't be able to do with a dialogue in
vs when we ship in September
it might take another six months for us
to get that through my heart is that oh
yeah we had a pendulum swing to command
line because we're still windows focus
it was so far behind - I use them Mac
for three years - to not use Windows so
I could be in that mindset and it kind
of hurt a little bit because I didn't
test LVS for features and we would have
good end to end um so we have to turn it
bounce between being not over Windows
pivoted and still supporting the aunt
ends it's mostly because the team grip
on Windows somebody you're still used to
Windows so ha if you wanna be serious
doing done it the cross-platform net
development you need to live in the
other world right and having people live
in that world sometimes you forget about
the world you have already so now we're
trying to figure out on team how do we
balance having people that are deeply
experts in the other OS is also and also
having any experiences on TSM VS code
and VF for Mac is challenging I saw
gentlemen here so it's be the last
question for repeat it so he's asking
about ahead of time compilation in
particular about the orti project yeah
we we've had forms of a ot
you know since early on with the pre
ginning stuff that they were talking
about before NJ and stuff and they're
only sort of mild forms it's as we're
trying to save some work upfront
there was an experiment experimental
project that parts of the dotnet runtime
team started a while ago called karate
it's up on github there's been quite a
bit of interest from areas of the
community on that and then we announced
the spiders on their 5 that we wanted to
try and merge some of the great tooling
from mano with some of the with core
with the core CLR stuff as well and
basically make where it comes from isn't
really important but what we want to do
ender 5 and moving forward is have good
options for JIT based compilation as
well as good options for IOT and so we
care about it a lot where it lands yet
I'm not really sure because Donna five
is not even what I'm done think about
shipping down there through the moment
that necklace right but in short we care
about it a lot and I think we'll see
development there over the next few
months all right I'm gonna call a halt
to it Scott Allen Julie Lerman David
Fowler at Damien Edwards thank you very
much for your time to see me
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you